I used to watch when I was starting out
in comedy I would watch this Dave Gro
clip where he's like it was for people
like aspiring musicians it's like what
what should you do if you're an aspiring
musician he's like just play live man
just play Live you know and that's what
I would do I would just go and I just
play the drums as hard as I could yeah
and I equated that to Comedy I'm like
just just tell jokes man yeah yeah but
it it was like inspiring like he is very
inspiring I mean on that note you guys
used to inspire the [__] out of me at
the Westside Comedy Club oh thanks yeah
that's so nice man you've told us that
before it really means a lot thank I
must reiterate yeah back in those days I
you know I that was super just not
confident and bro the the I feel like
Westside comedy theater everyone really
knew each other I feel like you stood
out when you didn't know anyone MH that
was a good that and a lot of different
clicks would go to that one like some uh
shows are mics it would be just one
click and the Westside comedy theater
was like it's like the beginning of the
Warriors where all the different gangs
came
yeah so yeah I would just stand on the
back wall and I'd watch you guys go up
there and just
Crush dude I remember you had a set it
was it was like towards the end I think
you were like 18th or something there
were not many people there and you went
up there and like just ripped for three
minutes and I just was like man I'm bad
at this like I just wanted to
leave yeah dude oh thank you man I
appreciate that yeah man yeah those are
it is funny you always see Comics
talking about who are like farther ahead
like I always see like Ralphie May had
like this video where he's talking about
how to get into comedy they always talk
about open mics like that they're like
that was the time and you're sort of
like you're in open mics I loved it
because it's like you're working on new
stuff every day and it's like the
getting people to laugh it's like such a
cool feeling when it's so new yeah but
you're sort of like well how could how
could like touring not like be less fun
than right or what am I trying to say
like how can this be the best time
compared to like yes but it is true it's
like that that feeling where you're just
like new and and just working on stand
up and like starting to like get people
to it's like the best feeling and then
the the camaraderie is just so so much
fun yeah when you can get something to
hit at a Open Mic it's like like okay
yeah yeah especially if it's not like
dirty or like uh or like really brutal
yeah yeah then you're like whoa this
joke is yeah must work it's ready for
TV I made all these like cuz cuz at open
mics the comics they only want to laugh
at like the most like brutal inhumane
yeah like something awful has to have
happened to you and so if you can make a
joke about like pineapples and it works
you're like okay yeah I have something
this is it yeah man you know what I
always loved was like at the random mics
when an actor who was just trying comedy
would go up they always stuck out to me
because they're always like just way
better looking than everyone yeah and I
I don't know why those characters always
just made me laugh like they get up
there and be like so I'm [__] this
chick and I'm like no one relates to
that here well everyone else there like
knew the assignment and would just
Stonewall
them they like let's see if you can
handle this goodlooking person and they
were so unaccustomed to failure that
they'd be like you'd see them in real
time like have to deal with life and
then you're like yeah sucks H bro it
sucks yeah and they're all mad tall yeah
they were just stra
but then some of those dudes would come
back you like all right yeah you're a
real one it it was funny seeing those
guys too cuz like their go-to almost
always was the like it's tough being so
hot yes yeah you know it's like it's
like it's like you know I'm just so hot
and no one takes me seriously and but
they're at an open mic for standup
comedy and everyone's like and they're
like
yeah yeah no one takes me seriously yeah
the the unified stone wall is so good
yeah yeah we all just look at each other
Ling arms we know what we're doing
here you shall not pass yeah yeah go
audition for Euphoria [__]
yeah their Toro was Cod yeah yeah I'm
allergic so you are to fish all fish to
Seafood man that's sick to Seafood yep
wow to seafood can you be near it I can
be near it I I I have to it's like super
mild it's just a very annoying allergy
like I'd have to eat a whole fish to go
anaphylactic how old were you when you
discovered it my mom used to force feed
it to me and then when I was like having
a reaction I'd tell her like my throat's
closing she just would not believe me
wow yeah damn she'd be like no keep
going she trying to toughen you up yeah
dude have you seen uh Bud Crawford's mom
have you seen those clips oh bro you got
to see it so you know Terence Crawford
dude his mom is like the most Savage mom
that ever lived she she we could we
could watch the clip but she used to be
like she'd like she would put a bounty
on bud in the neighborhood and she would
pay kids 10 bucks if they could beat Bud
up and then she was like none of them
could though and then Bud's like all I
ever wanted was her love and she never
gave it to him me and the interviewer is
like what would you tell him and she was
like that he wasn't going to be [__] oh
my God yeah it's pretty insane holy [__]
and he's like pretty healthy about it I
mean he talks about it in a healthy way
but he's like it put a rage in me I just
wanted to prove to her like I would
destroy the world to prove to her that I
was enough and he says it very like
plain and without emotion but you can
see it when he's fighting you're like
yeah you seem pissed off yeah that's I
mean that's how you raise an absolute
machine of a human whether it's a boxer
a CEO just tell your wife to not love
the son I think it's more effective if
it comes from the mom it is yeah cuz
from the dad you almost expect it and
from the Mom it's more of like a yeah if
your mother's like you're worthless it's
yeah cuz then you then you go your whole
life and you're like I'm worthless and
then uh you yeah you just don't think
you're worthy ever so you do all this
extra stuff to be worthy your son just
put on an amazing performance tonight
how do you feel Deborah what does this
mean to you I'm proud I'm
happy he always told me he can do
it he always going to be a pro boxer
what I did and he blew this mama WR bro
she has been a coach since day one this
is how coaches speak about their about
their maybe we're harder on her because
she's a mom cuz it seems like a
violation of nature but like if it was
like custom talking about I think he was
but we'd be like that's what he needed
yeah yeah yeah so so in a way maybe she
just saw the talent in him she's like
nah I can't give it to him but paying
neighborhood kids to beat up your son
pretty crazy is pretty crazy it's like a
level of like just uh harshness that I
I've never even heard of yeah it's it's
another clip if we want to watch it it's
it's a
it's pretty amazing I just yeah I got to
see this like I see him go it put a rage
in me I think it's the top right one on
the vide yeah I think it's this
one
no it's like a one minute one somewhere
probably on like Tik Tok or something we
could find it on the break and then drum
it back up but yeah it was pretty well
yeah you you boxed for a minute no I
mean I I I I've trained it SP a couple
times but I'm I'm I don't have much
power and I have heavy feet so I don't
think I'm welld designed for uh genuine
I do like doing it though like I'll box
friends once in a while cuz it does make
me feel closer to him afterwards like me
and my brother for my 30th he boxed me
which was really fun yeah did you go
headgear mouthpiece yeah headgear
mouthpiece the whole thing I tried it
when I was in high school I would box
and I was training for a while and then
I was at a party and I was a sophomore
and this kid who was a freshman Ryan he
had a reputation for being tough
everyone's like he's the toughest
freshman but we were about the same size
I was like I'll [__] him up let's box he
did not want to fight me I was like Ryan
box me every they started boxing at this
party I was like box me he's like Noah I
was like box me and he finally the peer
pressure he was like all right we got in
there he threw one punch I slipped he
threw another punch connected I fell off
a ledge I went into convulsions and I
woke up like 5 hours later at the
hospital and then he was in the hospital
crying cuz he thought he killed me so
really who won ah that'd be crazy you
walk up out you wake up out there you're
like look at you crying like a little
[__] look at you [__] at that point I
was like I was like a yeah I'm probably
not going to be a boxer but I wanted to
I liked it
yeah